وتقدما بشهادة صندوق النقد
والبنك الدوليين ان الجزائر قوية
الصهيوني. المسجد الاقصى.
الاحداث والتطورات اعلنت كوريا
الجنوبية اجراء مناورات جوية
مشتركة مع الولايات المتحدة شملت
اعترضت خمسة عشر من الصواريخ
التي اطلقت باتجاه منطقة الجليل.
بين ذهبت بقية الصواريخ هؤلاء.
اسرائيل تعلن حالة الطوارئ
وبعد معاودة قوات الكيان
الاسرائيلي اقتحام المسجد الاقصى
الاعتداء على المصلين والمعتكفين
بداخله. وفجأة ومن دون سابق
والرئيس البلاروسي يصل الى
موسكو. فهل هي زيارة عابرة? ام
بتوبيخ الصين او الضغط عليها.
وكانها تقول لهم عليكم ان تحلوا
خطيرة. اسرائيل تعلن حالة
الطوارئ. الوجع يزداد يا سادة.
الناتج المحلي بالانفاق الدفاعي
في الحلف. مؤكدا ان ما تريده
يخرج الحلف على المعاش. فهل اصبح
ضعيفا الى هذه الدرجة يا ترى
اخرى قدمت الخارجية الاردنية
طلبا لمجلس الامن بهدف عقد جلسة
قاذفة استراتيجية امريكية واحدة
على الاقل من طراز تو اتش قادرة
مظاهرات مطالبين بطرد السفير
الاسرائيلي في الاردن. من جهة
بالمنطقة لا شفا حرب نووية وفق
وكالة الانباء المركزية في كوريا
لحملة الرد على انتهاكات محتلة
واقتحام المسجد الاقصى بتنظيمهم
السادس عشر حتى الثلاث من يونيو
المقبل. وهنا وبعد اجتماع وزراء
الاعتداءات على المسجد الاقصى
مستمرة واقتحام المدن الفلسطينية
انذار انهالت عشرات الصواريخ على
الاسرائيلية. واذاعة الجيش
تلقاء نفسها كما فعلت قبلها
بهونج كونج. وهنا تقولها بكين
بيانا بانه وقع بقيمة سبعة
وعشرين مليون دولار مع شركة
بلقاء رئيستها مع رئيس مجلس
النواب الامريكي كيفن موكارتي في
كاليفورنيا بدأت بكين تدريبات
مكثفة في مضيق تايوان. فهل اقترب
للتوقعات. بوتين يواصل ارسال
اسلحته النووية نحو بلاروسيا
النقد الاجنبي بلغ حاليا اربعة
وستين مليار دولار خلافا
اقتصاديا وليس لديها مديونية
خارجية. وان احتياطي الجزائر من
الرئيس الجزائري عبدالمجيد تبون
ان اقتصاد الجزائر يشهد نموا
التي جرت بين الوزيرين تؤكد على
اهمية الاستقرار في المنطقة. كشف
الايراني والسعودي في بكين لتؤكد
الخارجية الايرانية ان المحادثات
الاوكراني ليقول ان روسيا لن
تهزم اوروبا بينما تقف اوكرانيا
بولندا ستساعد في تشكيل من القوى
الغربية بهدف تزويد اوكرانيا
لسان متحدثه ديمتري بسكوف الذي
عبر عن قلق موسكو ازاء الاسلحة
امريكية كورية جنوبية وبيونج
يانج انتم على شفا حرب نووية.
ايضا وفي الطرف الاخر الغارات
على الاراضي السورية لا تتوقف.
القصوى لتجتمع بشكل عاجل ويأتي
هنا الرد وتبدأ المدفعية باطلاق
الاقل من الاراضي اللبنانية.
مشيرة الى ان القبة الحديدية
على حمل اسلحة نووية لترد بيونج
يانج بان التدريبات العسكرية
المشتركة بين امريكا وكوريا
الجنوبية الجارية حاليا ستدفع
الشمالية. بعد اعادة الصلح بين
الطرفين التقى وزيرا الخارجية
صراحة ان تصرفات الادارة الحالية
في تايبي لن تغير حقيقة ان
طارئة لبحث الوضع الذي الت اليه
فلسطين وشعبها والحد من التصعيد
قذائفها على المناطق التي اطلقت
منها الصواريخ. لينضم الاردنيون
وواردة. لياخذ ماكرون الحديث
الصيني على محمل الجد. وها هو
الاسرائيلي تذكر ان الجيش سجل
اكثر من ثلاثين عملية اطلاق على
بوصلتها نحو الامريكيين. قائلة
انتم لستم في موقف يسمح لكم
تايوان جزء من الصين ولكنها
ستدفع الجزيرة الى شفا حرب
العيون الضيقة لن يتأخر. وبعد ان
وقع تايوان في المحظور الصيني
ابتلاع التيوان. الاستعدادات
جارية على قدم وساق. ورد اصحاب
شيئا فالصين تاجر والتاجر الاكبر
يكون على رأس ما له. الصين
ستستمر في استراتيجية الخنق
والحصار الى حين ترضخ تايوان من
السمك في الماء وادار الذخيرة في
الهواء. لم تستطيع الصين ان تفعل
لصناعة دبابات من نوع لاوكرانيا
كييف تطلب الطائرات وواشنطن تجهز
الصينية جاءت بالخبر اليقين
بقولها ان على الولايات المتحدة
الصين وفرنسا تمتلكان القدرة على
تجاوز الخلافات ما يمر العالم
يصل الى بكي. ويلتقي برئيسها شي
جين بينغ هذا الاخير قال ان
موعد الغزو مهلا مهلا. مناورات
ومناورات ومناورات. فما ذنب
لها الدبابات. هل هناك مشكلة في
اسماع الامريكان? الصين تقترب من
باعادة روسيا الى رشدها والجميع
الى طاولة المفاوضات. فهل يفعلها
اصحاب العيون الضيقة من يدري?
واما البنتاجون فتحرك فورا واصدر
تم ابادة السابقات تايوان تقترف
المحظور الصيني والجيش الصيني في
لكم بتوبيخنا. الولايات المتحدة
تحضر دبابات جديدة لاوكرانيا فهل
والزلنسكي يتجه لتوريط بولندا
لمواجهة الدب الروسي عسكريا فهل
ليعلن وزير الخارجية الامريكي ان
بلاده ستستثمر اثنين بالمائة من
زاخاروفا على هذا الاجتماع
بتأكيدها بان الاوان قد ان كي
اوكرانيا وبولندا واوروبا
والعالم باسره. ليقول زيلنسكي ان
هؤلاء فالعالم لم يعد يتحمل
اكثر. الاجابة هذه المرة جاءت
لمناقشتها. فهل ان نتفاءل
بانتهاء الازمة الاوكرانية.
واشنطن هو السلام العادل في
اوكرانيا. ومن الطرح الامريكي
الناتو علقت صاحبة الكلمات
اللاذعة المتحدثة الروسية ماريا
المتحدة الامريكية مع الدول
الشريكة في صربيا في الفترة من
ما افسدتموه بانفسكم لا ان
تعودوا للصين في كل شاردة
بتغييرات تاريخية كبيرة ليرد
ماكون بقوله انه يعول على بكين
والناتو ان يتحملا مسؤولية
الازمة في اوكرانيا. لتوجه
الدب الروسي? وكما يقولها المثل
المصري. اللي ما يشوفش من
والجزائر تخالف التوقعات وتثبت
جدارتها. فيما مصافحة تاريخية
الغربال يبقى اعمى. تورطت مع
هتلر قديما ودفعت فاتورة ثقيلة.
ليصرح بان روسيا سوف تراقب عن
كثب التدريبات العسكرية للولايات
وصافرات الانذار تدوي والرعب
ينخر عظام الاحتلال. ومناورات
المناسب على اي نشر اضافي لمثل
هذه الاسلحة في اوروبا. بينما
الاوكرانيسكي حينما يكون الوقت
والظروف مناسبين. لكن الخارجية
الرئيس الصيني شي جين بينغ
اخبرها بانه سوف يتصل بالرئيس
الى المبادرة الصينية. حيث صرحت
رئيسة المفوضية الاوروبية بان
بتوقيع الرئيس الاوكرانيسكي
اتفاقا مع رئيس الوزراء البولندي
لتوريد حزمة دفاعية جديدة ستحمي
ما وصفها بحرية واستقلال
حرب ضد موسكو فهنا تتجه اعين
الروس نحو صربيا حيث عاد بيسكوف
فهل تكررها مع بوتين? لكن بولندا
ليست وحدها من تتجه للتورط في
حالة تأهب قصوى وبكين تحرك
اسطولها البحري المرعب ووقت
مبادرة لانهاء الحرب في اوكرانيا
ليرد بوتين بانه على استعداد
يرسل بدفعة اسلحة جديدة الى
الاراضي البلاروسية. فهل يريد
اسلحة نووية استراتيجية الى
بلاروسيا ها هو بوتين مرة اخرى
يهابها العالم باسره ويتجاهلها
الاعداء. ليعلنها الكرملين على
النووية الامريكية في اوروبا.
مؤكدا ان روسيا سترد بالشكل
لوكساندر لوكاشينكو خلال لقائه
بالرئيس الروسي ان منسك حملت
وبولندا كتفا الى كتف. برأيكم هل
تقحم بولندا نفسها في خطر مواجهة
الخصوم ينفذ وكل يذهب نحو نار
الحرب بالمنفاخ. ويا لها من حرب
كان وزير الدفاع الروسي سيرجي
شويغو على ان بلاده ستتخذ
بطائرات حربية على غرار تحالف
الدبابات لتأخذ الحماسة الرئيس
بوتين نصب منصات هذه الاسلحة
بنفسه؟ يجيب الرئيس البلاروسي
اجراءات انتقامية وتدافع عن امن
حدودها. وبعد اعلان بوتين نقل
الاجتياح يقترب. رشقات صاروخية
على المستوطنات الاسرائيلية
يفعلها? التحضيرات لحرب كبرى
عالمية جارية على قدم وساق. فمن
حفلة انتقامنا بدأت فلتستعدوا
لما هو اعظم. هكذا اعلنتها موسكو
بين ايران والسعودية. روسيا تقرع
طبول الانتقال. طفح الكيل وصبر
يقص شريط الافتتاح وبكين
لواشنطن? انتم لستم في موقف يسمح
ان لدى بوتين ما يقوله للغرب من
هذا